Now,
in the last lecture we talked about how China,
uh,
has had this very dense population of very poor peasants for a very long time.
And,
uh,
we started discussing some of the possibilities for why that would be.
So we talked about the possibility that China just had a higher fertility rate
and roughly that was not true.
Um,
we found that the Europeans and the Chinese both had methods of controlling
their population.
It doesn't mean the methods were exactly equal,
but they were rather opposite.
The European method,
as you know,
was late marriage,
uh,
incomplete marriage that half or so,
40%,
50% of people never got married or run married at any given time.
A great deal of lack of marriage and late marriage meaning,
but once they got married,
they did not seem to have any limitation on their fertility.
And so half the people,
uh,
going at full tilt is sort of one hour clock and the Chinese situation tend to
25% of the girls who had done away with basically at birth,
the rest all got married.
But,
uh,
within a marriage they had a very low rate of reproduction,
show.
Uh,
at the end.
I don't think we'll have time,
but if we do,
I'll show you some of the evidence that this low rate of reproduction was not a
conscious effort to control fertility,
but was the result of the culture.
I,
I discussed,
I gave you that conclusion last number and give you any data there.
There's plenty of data for that.
So we're,
we're back to what the difference is between China and Europe.
You know,
why,
why are they so different when,
yeah.
When you say design,
do you mean design consciously?
No,
it's done.
I think the people had no idea.
People obey various cultural rules.
Cultural rules happen randomly.
You Can Watch anthropologists watch cultures and culture is a very flexible
thing and it changes fairly frequently.
If that change works,
people retain it in the whole culture works.
If that doesn't work,
either people change it again or the culture disappears.
Most cultures over time have disappeared.
Cultural Evolution seems to fall pretty much the same rules as biological
evolution.
Almost random change in biology.
You have random changes in the genome,
the cosmic ray hits you or you smoke a cigarette or or something like that,
uh,
and a base pair changes or you're a piece of chromosome jumps out and goes back
in,
inserted a lot of different things.
These are mostly bad changes,
but very,
very rarely.
There's a good change if it's a good change,
presumably that individual will have more children and so there's more copies of
that gene,
the next generation and so on.
You,
you know,
the basic story of evolution,
cultural evolution can be the same.
People change culture on the basis of fads and who knows what.
We've had a lot of evidence that even the great reduction in fertility that
we've seen all over the world has a lot of aspects of a fan that once a small
group adopts it,
everybody looks around and likes the idea of group fertility drops like a stone
way before and,
and,
and rather independently of economic changes in educational changes and
urbanization changes.
And a lot of the lectures have shown that that something is adopted for maybe
unclear reasons by a small group.
People like it.
It's like the kind of clothes that you wear or something and there's no
rationality to it.
But if it works,
it gets embedded in the culture.
So the uh,
so no,
I don't think there's any evidence that any of these practices were put into
place for the purpose that we now impute to them.
But there are practices that worked for that culture within the rest of their
ecological and cultural context.
And so it persistent.
That's a very important,
uh,
it's a good question,
is a very important way of thinking about culture that it evolves very much in
the same way that biology,
biological things evolve.
And it's a decent introduction to what I want to say today because one of the
strong aspects of culture is family
and of course in Chinese culture as,
as in many others,
it's really the very center of Chinese culture,
the family and other responsibilities to each other.
We talked and I'll go back over it a little bit about how loosely bound the
families in in Europe were all refer to this later,
but in China,
families are much more tightly bounded.
It's,
it's a much more functional unit.
And this binding a is ordered by Confucian doctrine,
uh,
for,
for a long time in China and this is women,
uh,
had to give absolute deference to men.
Children had to give absolute deference to parents and elders for instance.
The relationship between parents and children are extremely important.
And in China,
children did not leave the home in Europe.
Remmeber I described to you that age seven,
Charles Dickens is,
goes out and works and,
and,
and people are sent out to do service in different places or be apprentices.
That happened,
of course,
any,
everything happened in China.
But the most usual thing was that the children were kept at home and worked on
the family land.
The parents chose a spouse for the child.
Again,
in Europe,
people went out and had what they called Morgan Adic,
marriages,
marriages presumably for love.
But the parents were not involved in the marriage.
In China after marriage,
the sun remained living in his parents' compound and the daughter in law moved
in with them.
Very,
very standard kind of situation.
There was no separate economic unit for the marriage children as long as the
father lived,
he controlled the assets of all the family.
The children did not have independent stuff and money that they owned.
It was all under the control of the father and in old age it was the children
and not the community.
Uh,
who responsible for support of the parents.
That was part of the tit for tat.
Again,
in the culture,
this is very closely range.
The parents have responsibilities toward the children.
The children have responsibilities towards the parents.
The parents support the children when they're young,
provide land for them,
uh,
when they inherit the land.
But in return the children must support the parents in old age.
Living in the family of your,
your,
your parents,
uh,
is a very conservative,
effect because the older generation gets to dictate the customs and morays and
the behavior of the younger generation and older generations are by definition
conservative cause they were brought up in an older version of things and there
may be modern things going on but they don't generally accept them.
And so the respect to fertility,
the SPEC to son preference of a boy who may be 17 marries a girl who may be 13,
14,
15,
the girl and the boy is under the thumb of his mother and the girl moves into
the enter the house and she's only 13 and she's under the thumb of everybody.
And the mother insists that she get pregnant right away and have a boy.
And she describes it as for my son's benefit,
that,
that the cultural thing is she's doing it so that my son will pass on the family
name.
It's good for my son,
but the son probably doesn't want it.
And when as times modernize,
he wants to enjoy his life and enjoy his,
his wife and so forth.
But they have little power of the son and the daughter in law had little power.
It's the grandparents that have the cultural power in the family.
So it's very,
uh,
conservative,
factor in,
in cultures and uh,
especially in matters of reproduction.
So,
uh,
in the return as I mentioned for children giving up autonomy,
which,
which they give up their children very much under the control of the parents and
for living in this absolute deference,
uh,
fathers in a lot of China at different times in their history had the right to
kill a child if the child would was disobedient and that was not,
not against the law.
Um,
uh,
in return for this,
they had a support that children of all ages find spouses and assure resources
for the next generation.
And the essence is since they really,
the only resource that,
that peasants generally have is some land that meant giving the children land
for the next generation.
In England,
especially in a lot of the rest of your day,
practice primogenitor that only the oldest son got the land.
And so the holdings,
whatever amount of land and the parents had was kept together,
the Chinese did not practice primogeniture and you're talking about a lot of
place over a long time.
So I'm sure there were some places where it happened.
But in general,
uh,
they did not practice primogenitor.
So on the death of the father of the family land would be divided up among
however many sons that there were.
They said the good benefit that no one was forced.
And one of the cultural reasons for it that we'd land.
You could start a family,
you could have children,
you can have sons.
So no one would be forced into the situation,
which was unbearable in traditional Chinese culture of not having a son.
You had to have a son.
We're going to have a son,
you how to have a wife,
not have wife you have means and supporting her a little bit.
So the family had to give you land.
So this factor,
the lack of,
uh,
the division of family land in China had a tremendous impact on the whole
economic situation of China.
Of course,
as population grew that guaranteed that the plots of land would get smaller and
smaller and smaller and right down to the subsistence level
a common Chinese and the Chinese were very well aware of this.
Uh,
uh,
a common Chinese saying which summarize this phenomenon says fortunes seldom
continue considerable in the same family beyond the third generation.
Yeah.
If you're Chinese and say that we have similar sayings in the Western world,
but they're very different meanings in China,
what it means if you are,
uh,
have a fortune.
If you're rich,
you'll be able to keep more of your children alive,
including the sons.
If you have more sons,
you have to divide your land into more small pieces and you go right back to the
poverty level.
When we say things like that,
and the west,
it means the first generation works very hard,
is honorable in a sense,
makes money.
The second generation seen their parents work,
retain some of that work were worth that good work ethic.
But the children,
the grandchildren grow up rich and they're there,
they're rotters.
They don't work very hard.
So the same cultural impression of,
of uh,
works in both cultures that rich has don't last very long and generations,
but one is due to the scarcity,
the division of land and one is due to the,
the,
the personality of the individual.
And uh,
Maltis knew about this saying the saying is so popular.
Trend Maltis knew about this saying and wrote about it 200 years ago and it's
uh,
still still common.
I read it a Chinese saying may the New York Times a few years ago.
Okay.
And again,
this is in contrast to the European situation where children left home early to
work in a succession of other chap households.
They chose their own spouses very interestingly as evidence of,
of this kind of disillusion that in most of the world we have these tight
families.
When someone get married,
there's some record of it.
There's some registry through a personal family rec record kept as a family
treasure or some governmental or village or religious record.
And in all,
in all these countries with tight marriages,
there's a long list of relatives that have witnessed the wedding and say,
yes,
this,
this is true.
Not In England.
There's the,
the,
the list.
It's the two people go to church or a priest or a minister marries them and
that's it.
The family can be involved but need to have nothing to do with it.
And legally it doesn't have anything to do with it,
uh,
after marriage,
unless they are the primogenitor son that is inheriting the father's household,
they go and set up their own household somewhere else and live separately there.
Economic,
as soon as they get married,
they're economically independent of their parents.
And one Dataset in 75% of cases in,
in northwest Europe,
children didn't even live in the same village where their parents lived.
So it wasn't like they were really close,
but they moved away.
Now again,
in cultures,
all these,
a lot of things have to fit together.
So the system of independence,
the European system can only occur if some provisions made for supportive the
elderly.
Because in China,
the,
the young,
the children have the responsibility to take care of the overlay and this has to
happen.
All elderly need to be taken care of.
And the culture would never evolve successfully if,
if there wasn't some way of European,
uh,
oldsters getting some sort of support.
But interesting in Europe it was not the children who are responsible for
support of the elderly.
Uh,
but the community had that responsibility.
in from 1598 parliament as a long time ago,
1598 parliament are required overseers of the poor to be appointed every year in
every parish in the country.
Absolutely system.
Every parish was responsible for its own,
uh,
poor.
And which was mostly elderly.
And they not only had the duty to
support anybody that came and asked for it,
who was indeed poor,
they had to go out and identifying the poor.
They had to the poor there that were too helpless or too ignorant or didn't
know.
They had the responsible to go out and identify the poor.
And we have a lot of argumentation about are the America,
especially about our current welfare state.
How much effort should the welfare agencies do to pull in clients for their
services to advertise their services?
Well,
1598 England have faced of course the same issue.
And the parliament then decided that no,
the responsibility of the community was to go out and identify fine people who
needed help.
And these,
uh,
these overseers were empowered to levy taxes sufficient to pay for this.
So the law was very clear that the primary responsibility for providing relief
lay with the parish,
that that was where it happened.
And there was no direct obligation recognize between the child and the parent.
A parent could not go and sue his children,
uh,
for support.
But there was a back door,
a little loophole that once the parish discharge his responsibility and
supporting the poor,
then the parish could go and sue the child to re Rican reimburse the parish for
it's,
it's expensive.
So it wasn't totally that,
that,
that the children get off the hook.
But that was when her children lived in a different village.
And this was all very localized.
It was a very hard thing to enforce.
And basically it was the community that had this responsibility.
Colonial America picked up that same pattern and there are really quite horrible
stories of pregnant women who either got pregnant out of wedlock or whose
husband had died or had gone off to a war or something sort of being chased from
village to village while they were pregnant and ready to give birth because of
the village knew that if that child was born in that village,
they would ever have to have to do poor relief for the mother and the child.
And there's some really unpleasant stories from,
from colonial America.
Well,
so you have two different patterns.
Uh,
uh,
Chinese and of course not limited to China where the children are under the
thumb of the grandparents,
especially the grandmother and reproductive matters.
And so behavior is not terribly flexible.
It's whatever the older generation believe.
Whereas in Europe,
children go out and form their own households and they can respond more easily
to changes in,
in cultural Milan's
the younger boys,
it's quite interesting,
the while one of the results of the primogenitor is one,
you keep the plots together so that in the,
in the peasantry you don't have this enormous class of terribly poor peasants.
Peasants retain a reasonable amount of land,
but all the rest of the sons go off to the cities and uh,
they get,
they get forced off the land.
And demographically they usually don't,
don't require the resources to get married because in the cities it's very hard
to,
to accumulate the resources.
Uh,
so they never get married.
They never have children.
As I mentioned before,
the death rates in the cities who are so incredibly high that,
uh,
about,
every generation,
about a third of the,
of the,
of the city people die and had to be replaced by new immigrants from the country
side.
But still there was quite a large population of unemployed or barely employed
people in the cities.
And what did they do?
They joined armies.
That's one of the big specialty of,
of men big require manpowers.
And some historians believe that the,
the aggressiveness of Europe,
all the constant wars that Europe or in during this period in the colonial
expansion,
we do it all these young men in the army and they had to do something with them
that,
that or reverse,
they were available.
All these young men were available for the army.
And so they were employed to do whatever the rulers believe that they should do.
Uh,
they also,
uh,
try to make a living in the city and did a lot of apprentice ship and they would
start a small trade or some hand manufacturing operation.
And again,
some historians believe that this excess of,
of,
of males in the city trying to cope on their own,
were formed one of the bases for the industrial revolution.
So the two systems,
uh,
were really dying.
The European Shiny,
we're sort of diametrically opposite.
And the Chinese system was in a sense,
much kinder because no one would,
in Europe,
children was sort of basically sacrificed goodbye,
have a good time in life,
we'll see ya.
I,
whereas in China they were,
they were kept at home in the security of the family and its land,
which is both emotionally more secure and economically more secure,
but very poor.
Um,
so,
so it looks like that this very practice,
which is,
is the center of Chinese culture,
the tightness of the family,
respect too for elders,
lack of adolescent rebellion and et Cetera,
older,
the characteristic of things that go along with that may also be one of the
reasons why China suffered now through z and in the Malthusian misery situation
for so long that the,
the land parcels in which people try to survive with just so tiny that they were
up against the,
uh,
an absolute limit.
Okay.
All right.
We can see in the statistics the result of this keeping people on the land.
Um,
China basically as,
as observed by Chinese and by everyone else.
Uh,
it became what was called a vast sea of impoverished rural peasants.
As late as 1994% of Chinese lived in villages,
meaning they were agricultural there online countries in England a hundred years
earlier in 1800.
The agricultural population was down to 37,
37%.
So China was way more than a hundred years behind England,
at least in,
in urbanizing and industrializing and so forth
without enough land.
Nonetheless,
uh,
when plots got so small that people really could not survive on them.
Of course,
even in China,
they had to leave the land and you've a class of landless laborers as there
really was everywhere.
But the,
the conditions which they left in Europe,
the poverty in on the farms was so much worse than say an in Europe that when
they moved to the cities,
it was even a step,
a step further down.
And this is really a disastrous,
in 1930s,
they,
both Americans and and Chairman Mao,
Mao did some of his earliest scholarly work investigating conditions of the
rural poor in China.
And so there's a fair amount of data that in the 1930s wages,
uh,
that we paid for,
labor.
What you paid a man to work for a day was the same as it cost you to,
to provide fodder for a donkey.
So the cost per day of a donkey.
And a human where the same,
it was such absolute misery,
but which,
which do people prefer to hire by a donkey or hire a human?
Same cost per day.
What?
Okay.
All the things that donkeys are humans can do,
but donkeys especially what kind of donkey do carries things?
It turns out that they prefer to hire the human.
Why?
Because if you have a donkey,
you have to pay them every day.
Even when the donkey is not working.
If you have a human,
you pay him for that day.
Essentially a subsistence wages,
just enough food to keep going,
which is more or less the same as the donkey and when you don't need them,
when the,
when the harvest is gone or you don't have anything to carry by,
you know.
So,
uh,
that's,
that's what you see in the Chinese cities of all this time that there was very
little mechanized transport.
Not Everything was carried by road,
by rickshaw carry.
Ritual is a seat.
But you know,
human laborers were carrying all the goods around the cities and between cities
and in the forums.
Also a labor was so cheap and human.
There was so many humans per land that,
uh,
there was no,
there was no economic incentive to get animals to do your heavy labor.
So there's an absence of draft animals in China and amazing difference between
Europe and trying as the absence of,
of draft animals.
And it's very instinct.
Draft animals not only provide you pulling labor,
but they provide manure and Europe had plenty of manure from all the liquor that
a lot of animals and Chinese then had to go to human manure.
And that the whole industry of,
of,
of spreading the human manure nights,
soil,
as they call it on the fields,
is due to a lack of,
of draft animals.
So in this,
uh,
this,
this continued,
uh,
as late as the 1970s,
some parts of China was still too poor to have farm animals.
And so you didn't get mechanized farming,
you didn't get any of the Labor was so cheap that didn't get any of the
mechanization of either motorized transport in cities or,
uh,
agricultural machinery and in the countryside.
Okay.
So
this kind of people coming down to a very,
very,
because the land got so crowded,
people coming down to a very,
very poor state of existence.
Uh,
it was really a great weakness of China.
And while at the top of the emperor and the court,
uh,
were,
were fabulously wealthy,
there was based on the backs of a mass of really,
really poor peasants.
And so when Europe,
uh,
develop good shipping and modern arms starting to develop modern armaments,
they were able to,
uh,
thrust their power all the way from Europe around most of the world.
It's not very easy to get by by sailing ship from Europe to China.
But by the early 18 hundreds,
Europe could project enough military power into China to defeat the Chinese
armies.
And as I mentioned last time,
uh,
the British were,
by that time having a terrible trade deficit with China.
The British were addicted to tea and they were losing all their money and the t
addiction would have choked the,
their,
their ledgers are very clear how that England was just losing all its money.
And if,
uh,
if they didn't restore the balance of trade,
Europe would be bankrupt and would have cut off the industrial revolution,
the money that could have fueled the industrial solutions.
In fact,
going to China to feed a caffeine addiction,
it was really a massive,
massive effect.
And so the British started importing opium into China from India as an attempt
to reverse the balance of trade,
which you did.
I mentioned this,
the Chinese put down their foot and said,
no,
you can't addict my people.
The British tried,
cried free trade invaded China in the first and the second opium war.
So by about 1840,
it was clear that China was a paper tiger.
No,
apparently that there's only had a vast number of people in a very strong
autocratic state.
They could not respond to western military power.
And,
uh,
once kicked out of the,
so for short interim there,
before the opium war,
the Chinese were able to kick the opium smugglers out.
Where'd they go to a little rocky island off the coast of south China.
And that's now called Hong Kong.
It started a smuggler's den.
And all the,
basically the big,
uh,
Jardine,
Matheson,
all the big British fortunes that stemmed from the China trade.
We're,
we're there,
we're really opium trade,
drug trade,
the things.
So the British started a controlling parts of China.
Then the Germans moved in,
the French moved in,
and the Americans,
when in the periods when Chinese government had some power,
we're very happy to intermediate and the drug trade and,
and help,
help avoid certain restrictions on the,
on the Brits and so forth.
And then the Japanese got modernized in the early 19 hundreds and they invaded
China.
And the end result of this is that from the first opium war for 115 years,
China was basically at the mercy of the European and imperial powers and the
Japanese,
uh,
newly imperial state.
And the,
the,
the final chapter on that,
of course is world war two,
when the Japanese invaded.
And we're incredibly brutal to the Chinese.
And I read you,
uh,
sometime back,
a story about the rape of Nanking.
And then after that,
there was a battle between the communists and the nationalists.
One by the comes a very,
very vicious civil war.
Uh,
basically China was devastated by this hundred,
hundred,
15 or years of dissolution of the government and,
and being taken advantage of by foreign powers.
The scarcity of land.
Just as a sort of a footnote to that history,
the scarcity of land,
uh,
remains a major problem for China,
especially the dry in hilly land.
You may remember last time I told her that as American foods came in and farming
increased,
that people learned that they could grow food on hilly land and dry and dry
land.
And so the population expanded into this,
uh,
marginal land
February and the end of February,
this year,
just a month ago.
Uh,
there was a story in the times and China's now going through the worst drought
in half a century,
which also means that they go through this every half century.
So it's not really an incredibly unusual thing.
And in the week band,
farmer's land is one third of an acre.
And remember I told you the average farm size is only one 10th of an acre.
So this guy's rich.
He's got a third of an Acre,
three times as much.
Why does he have so much?
Because it's carved out of a rocky hillside in a dry region,
so you can't survive on a 10th of an Acre there.
You need a three tenths of an acre.
The aquifers have been so depleted that in some farming regions,
wells have to go down a half a mile before striking water.
All the water that's less further down has already been used up,
and so they're going through this drought.
These people in good times,
on the third of an acre,
on a hilly,
rocky,
dry hillside,
you're not going to make a lot.
And now with the economic collapse in the world,
there's millions of migrant workers coming back into the farm,
the countryside,
and they're going to have to now somehow be supported on this very,
very poor agriculture.
Okay,
so finally after the Korean War,
and I met,
forgot to mention the Korean War,
where the United and some elements United States said they were going to invade
China.
This was the time when they were threatening to bomb trying to back to the stone
age.
Do you know that,
you know that expression.
So,
you know,
it was Senator William Nolan from California who was the main advocate of
bombing China back to the stone age.
Uh,
so,
uh,
but the US did not invade China and China fought,
fought them in North Korea.
Very,
very nasty bloody,
uh,
situation.
Uh,
but they,
they finally got this piece.
The data seems to show that in 1952,
which is at the end of,
of the Korean War,
Chinese had a significantly lower per capita income than they had at the end of
the Song Dynasty in the 13th century that there had been,
you know,
700 years with a six,
700 years with no progress,
a real progress for the people whose real mouth,
who's in situation where the population had grown up tremendously.
Production had increased tremendously,
but the two equaled out and no net progress.
So there's the new communist government,
which was very powerful and not,
uh,
not hesitant about using its power and being very autocratic,
but right away they did a number of very good things.
They invested very heavily in,
in public health and introduced the very basic measures of hygiene,
disease control and pest control.
It's a big thing.
Loudspeakers,
this period,
loudspeakers everywhere in China were blaring to the people.
You didn't have any time to think of their loud speakers everywhere at you.
Uh,
honorable elders,
please do not spit on the ground any.
Your Chinese have heard this or stories this you have.
And,
and there was a big campaign to Swat flies that just flies.
We're spreading disease from,
from the feces,
which was not in not flushed away and toilets.
So flies would step the feces and step onto you have you get thing.
So the same thing.
Swat a fly and they killed zillions of flies and it flies eventually did get
controlled in China.
And whether it was due to the swatter fly campaign or not,
uh,
I don't know.
But due to these things by 1957 which when we have a devastated country where
the government takes control,
and for nine years,
eight years,
the death rate went to half.
What had had been,
that's an amazing,
amazing achievement.
But when you cut the death rate in half,
what happens?
Population explosion.
So China had its most extreme population explosion after the communists came to
power.
Now these were not,
not ignorant people.
Were they worried about the puppet?
Supposing the answer is absolutely not.
Marx's theory is very pro natalist.
Mark's hated Maltis.
There's a long literature of Communists,
socialists invective against,
against small office.
They are really opposite poles.
Now it's sort of,
uh,
sort of the right wing and the extreme left wing that opposes morphis and
liberals and moderates are more predisposed toward him.
But anyway,
the mix,
his theory is basically says this,
look in a capitalist economy,
uh,
the capitalists take workers,
they employ them in factories and they make a surplus.
They,
they,
so the capitalist lives very well on the surplus.
The socialist economy can do just as well.
It can employ the workers,
they can make a surplus over them.
But instead of having big fat mansions in cigars,
the socialist candidate,
we'll reinvest the money for the good of the people.
So the more people,
the merrier.
Mark's original Marxist doctrine.
It was very,
very clear that since the capitalists can exploit labor,
so can,
can,
so can the state and that will redound to the benefit of the people.
So,
uh,
the way,
the way this was translated from Mark's into China,
they call mouth and says theory,
something like Ren all Lune,
which means man mouth theory,
which means that every man is born with a mouth.
He's a consumer.
And that splits up the pie.
But the marks is translate their theory as um,
uh,
I've got it somewhere here and I don't remember what it is,
but man,
hand theory that a man is born not only with a mouth to consume but a hands to
do work.
And the question is if the,
that the socialist state can employ the hands to produce more than the mouth
requires.
So they didn't buy,
they,
they were very,
uh,
in favor of a high population.
So in 1949,
mal becoming in charge of a very devastated country says in this quote,
revolution plus production will enable China to feed and employed the large and
growing population.
No worry until they got some facts.
1953 the country was stable enough that they took their first national census.
At that time,
they thought they had something like 426 million people and that the number had
not been growing in the century because of all the civil and foreign worlds and
natural calamities in China was a disaster.
So they thought,
well,
population could,
can't grow under those situations.
But then they took a census and they counted 600 million people,
which was 50% more,
uh,
a third larger than they had expected that were there.
And the error,
what they expected to find and what they did find was equal to the whole us
population at that time.
So it was big,
a big shock.
So they finally responded a rationally and immediately.
China pass the contraceptives and induced abortion act,
legalizing the importation in sale of contraceptives and legalizing
sterilization and abortion.
It's one small problem.
They didn't have any contraceptives,
they didn't have the manufacturing facilities.
So they legalize the importation of them and imported they Chinese had,
well,
no foreign currency at that time.
It was way,
way before any kind of economic progress.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
they just didn't,
didn't have it.
And the city's gotten,
you know,
there were always some money in the city.
So the city has got some of the foreign contraceptives,
uh,
and but,
in the countryside where the vast,
vast majority of the people lived at the time had basically no access.
And if they did have access,
they would have been able to afford them.
So the government policy was basically a meaningless.
And so what was the government to do?
So in,
in 56,
they realized that just proclaiming something doesn't,
doesn't help.
So they said,
well,
let's use traditional medicine.
And uh,
so,
uh,
they,
they asked all the traditional Chinese doctors,
you know,
what to do,
how you must have traditional ways of,
of contraception,
of,
of keeping women from having children.
And,
uh,
one of these became very well popularized,
popularized in the press on the third day following her period,
a woman should ingest 14 live tadpoles,
then 10 the next day.
And then the woman would be assured sterility for five years.
If the woman did this twice than traditional medicine,
said that the woman will be permanently sterile.
It's not totally clear whether this was the policy that the government was
really behind.
This is the procedure of governments.
But the press picked us up and it was a very big press thing,
uh,
in China and was,
it was very,
um,
very much followed by the people.
And the,
the very small ecological movement in China really got worried to China.
Then frogs would go extinct because people are eating all the,
all the tadpoles.
So finally the Chinese Academy of Science took it up,
uh,
got this distinct and I get did some experiments.
I don't know exactly what they did,
but they said,
no,
this doesn't work.
And so,
okay,
it's kind of go back through,
back to the drawing.
What are we going to do?
So the next round,
57,
58,
was used acupuncture as a contraceptive [inaudible] puncture and try has never
been used for the kinds of things it is used for here.
And there's no evidence of any effect from this for anything except the spread
of hepatitis because the needles weren't sterilized.
You can see that throughout Asia.
I may have mentioned this in the previous lecture,
but so they said,
okay,
let's try it for contraception.
And of course that didn't work any better or whatsoever.
So,
um,
so politically the government,
again,
it's a very new thing and the traditional Marxists,
we're still opposed to family planning and other more modern aspects.
The government on favorite,
so the government was uncertain and divided on this.
But in 1956,
the premiere join lie at the time,
very powerful guy urged limitations on childbirth.
And he was supported by influential economists who were very much influenced by
Western ideas,
but from Martha's onward Western ideas on population.
But the very next year,
so in 56,
which was when they started all this really trying to push a birth control,
the very next year,
that was one of the Chinese purges and 57,
they had the,
uh,
the campaigning,
the what they call the anti rightest campaign and people who are too influenced
by Western ideas.
And Western economic ideas.
Remember Malthus is considered the father of western economics were purged and
with them when,
uh,
the family planning a campaign.
So in the end,
the early back and forth thing on,
on family planning came to no effect.
There were no methods,
no train family planning personnel and no facilities in rural area and no
tradition of anything.
In 1958,
uh,
the party started organizing communes and you probably know a fair amount about
them.
These were giant agricultural enterprises with something like 5,000 families in
a single communion communion mean all the production from all the farm land it
owned by 5,000 families was pooled and they produce together and they consume
together.
And that particular summer for climatic reasons,
the harvest was,
was turned out to be excellent.
And as the data came in,
the,
the leaders of,
of Communist China at the time decided that the communes were the answer.
Look at how well we've done under this commune system and the [inaudible],
the lower down cadres who are going to be rewarded or punished depend on their
production.
They,
of course,
inflated figures,
uh,
wildly.
And,
uh,
they,
they claim that the rural production I had doubled,
had increased 10 fold or even scores of times.
So it was really,
there was indeed a good harvest,
but then that got inflated enormously due to the,
uh,
so we say the weak political process.
Um,
and so in 58,
after a couple of years of trying this,
uh,
officially pushing family planning,
but,
but without any,
any real policy that worked,
and with getting rid of the rightest who were in favor of it,
in 58,
they reversed again.
They went away from family planning and they,
they said,
uh,
the central,
the Communist Party's central committee said in 1958 that the communes were so
successful that China no longer had to worry about overpopulation to the
contrary.
The forthcoming problem would be quote,
not so much overpopulation as the shortage of manpower.
And basically what they get carried away with Jonathan Spence and his history of
China talks about this and says,
the vision of Utopia was altogether intoxicating.
Whenever your,
your view of the world gets out of kilter with the reality,
disasters is right behind.
And the disaster was indeed not far behind.
And that was the great leap forward.
So the context of the great leap forward is that the u s in particular had
threatened China,
had been threatening China with nuclear,
basically annihilation.
And now had answered with this that I have so many people,
if you kill a couple of hundred million,
who cares,
you know,
very,
very brutal,
uh,
response and counter and counter response.
But the answer,
Mao and everybody trying new ways to industrialize as fast as they possibly can
to catch up to America in military might.
And he decided that China was not industrializing fast enough and had to catch
up to the western level right away.
And so he told,
he ordered the orders,
went out from the central bureaucracy,
uh,
to put all their efforts into industrialization.
Forget about farming.
We have plenty of food.
The communes are producing plenty of food.
We don't have to worry about that.
Uh,
in fact,
in your backyard,
put iron smelters in,
build,
build little furnaces.
And,
and,
and smell your iron in your backyard.
And so people didn't have any iron ore.
So what they did,
they took their pots and pans,
put it into the smelter,
then they took their farm implements and put it in into the shelter.
And if you're from China,
remember your parents or somebody talking about these days.
Again you're doing,
we don't have too many native borns there,
but it was a very,
very big thing though.
The backyard iron.
And it resulted in two things.
One,
when you destroy agricultural implements,
your I go to a really does go go to hell.
And the iron that you can smell it in backyards is not very good iron.
So it's not very actually very useful.
But decide result is that agricultural production crashed,
absolutely crashed at the same time as part of the communes.
The communal kitchens were established where everyone could get together and the
purpose of they're the original purposes was twofold.
One,
they want Chinese work very hard to modernize the country,
to build up the country.
And each family going home for lunch and dinner is a huge amount of labor
involved in preparing meals,
especially with a fairly primitive of food cooking and gathering,
preparing technology.
And so if you have a staff dedicated per food and you make food for thousands of
people,
it can be done very efficient in terms of time.
It's economically very efficient sort of thing.
It also was a fit pro feminist measure that who had to do the work at home was
the women,
the women were working in the fields,
then the men could come home and relax,
but the women had to then take care of the children and bill the food.
So it was both an economic rationalization measure and it was a pro feminist
measure put.
The result was that consumption sword,
uh,
traditionally like all poor people around the world,
the Chinese are very a abstemious.
No,
every grain of rice counts in,
in a,
in a poor family.
If there's food available,
you eat just exactly what you need to stay alive and you store away the rest for
the future because the future is always very uncertain.
But when you have a communal kitchen,
it doesn't do any good to not eat your fill because if you don't eat your fill
someone,
someone else will.
There's no individual,
uh,
accounting,
no individual responsibility.
So everyone ate a lot and consumption sword at just the time that production is
going down.
And The d,
The concatenation of those two things was,
it was the disaster.
And as the disaster unfolded,
China was sufficiently authoritarian at the time that the,
the cadres have to pass up good news to the higher levels.
So news of the disaster that was unfolding before,
uh,
the local people's eyes was not passed up higher levels.
And apparently the higher levels really believed that the agriculture was
keeping up with all this consumption or the higher levels only receiving,
especially now cause evenly glowing reports of production,
agricultural production in the countryside.
So what happened was the great famine of the great leap forward,
several hundred million people,
uh,
became under nourished,
during this period.
And then people start sources undernourishment and then people starved massive
famines from 59 to 61.
We don't know how many people died in these famines.
The estimates are 20,
30,
40,
50 million people dying of starvation.
But what it was,
we don't know.
So this is uh,
let me show you the other one for us.
This is an old,
this is world population and you can go it back further except for the black.
There is no other bleeds.
See that blip there?
That's the great leap forward in China as part of world population there is,
if you carry world population back further,
you don't see any blip like that except the black death.
All the other disasters are not comfortable with this shows sort of a western
aesthetic going from something like a,
a loss of 30 or 40 million people.
The official Chinese statistics show the death rate going from 10 million to 25
million.
And you have to look at the area and that cause there's one,
two,
three years of it.
So they're estimating more like maybe 25 million deaths.
This,
the official Chinese statistics.
And of course in that extreme poverty that the birth rate just,
just crashes and then recovers when,
when food becomes available again.
So the,
the,
the moral of the story is that,
uh,
the Chinese seem to have a,
in the early stages of,
of the commune system,
the Chinese seem to have eradicated famine.
They had had 115 years of miserable history.
The communists come in,
things get better very quickly,
very fast.
They decide,
they have the answer,
they decide they don't have to pay attention to basic realities like population.
And uh,
so they get a very unreal view of reality.
And meanwhile,
the country is actually still walking on the edge of disaster before they were
under the edge and falling off to disaster before the revolution,
after revolution,
they were still on the edge.
But that wasn't realized.
So was stupidity.
A political mistake pushes them over the edge and you have this huge amount of
death.
And so you should be aware that when people talk about,
you know,
environmental limits,
what happens with population and the world,
that there's all kinds of physical limits to the number of people.
But the most delicate thing that humans make,
other social and political arrangements,
when things get very tight,
it's almost always not an underlying fundamental resource problem or something.
It's people's political response to it.
There their interpersonal response to it that goes out of whack and they start
making massive mistakes like this and then the world false,
false apart.
So it's the political and social arrangements that people make with each other
that are the most delicate and,
uh,
population stress we'll usually have it's disaster effects through acting
through the political and social arrangements.
Okay.
Then the Chinese did not have any rest after this.
Uh,
the great leap forward of the 60s and the early sixties got transformed into the
cultural revolution of the mid sixties,
sixties,
and there was more cows and after the great famine and the government learned
its lesson and again tried to institute birth control,
Flip Flop,
flip flop.
And again,
the method was largely a propaganda
and the kind of propaganda this time was aimed a lot at men and the kind of
things that the cronies press,
we're counting we're men before the age of 25.
Remember again,
it's a restriction on the young men from sex were described as if you have sex,
excessive dissipation of blood,
bodily fluids,
sexual neurasthenia,
low spirits,
headaches,
discomfort all over the body.
Emaciation dizziness,
tension,
memory loss,
premature old age,
mental and physical pain and impotence.
Now I've heard this from students as as their problems,
but they usually now attribute to lack of sex.
But the Chinese at that time were attributed to sex.
So you,
you take your chances.
Nevertheless,
uh,
the situation in the cities was such that the conditions there,
the housing scares scarcity,
the poverty were such that people indeed in the cities did,
uh,
reduce their fertility.
And by 1960,
somewhere in 1964 and 1966,
a window of the urban fertility drop too low,
three births per woman.
Uh,
uh,
and by 1974,
urban nonagricultural,
uh,
women,
their fertility was reduced to replacement level.
So rather rapidly urban fertility came down and it's continued to come down.
And in 1980,
it was one,
1.1 very low,
uh,
urban,
fertility,
but during the culture revolution had,
had remained very high cause it was chaos and nobody was watching the store.
In 1970,
it was 6.4 among rural women,
6.4 children,
which is basically the traditional number from way,
way back.
And so there was basically no conscious,
no conscious fertility control among the rural women.
By 1969,
the population past 800 million and in 1970 21% of births,
one out of five were first births,
17%,
almost the same.
We're second births.
But 62% were third or higher order births in in 1970.
So almost everyone was having three or more children.
So when political stability was finally restored after the disruption of,
of,
of the cult,
the great leap forward than the culture revolution,
the government really introduced a serious vigorous family planning program
starting in 1971.
Uh,
they introduced the port in one,
she shao later,
longer,
fewer.
And what they proposed was later marriage,
uh,
longer birth into roles leading to fewer children over all.
And uh,
this was propagandized very heavily,
but it's debate,
this is debatable,
but there was generally considered to be not an awful lot of coercion involved
in,
it was more or less a voluntary,
uh,
campaign.
And I want to show you one graph if I can.
Okay.
Here's the graph of the total fertility rate in China.
And I have,
I've taken out the years,
I'll show you the years in a minute.
When do you think,
so you had the one,
she shall the voluntary policy and then that lasted for about 10 years.
And then you had the one child policy,
which was at least in the beginning,
not very voluntary.
And you've heard about that.
Where do you think,
uh,
the one trial,
the one child policy starts,
we're in this graph,
the effectiveness of political programs.
No idea
what was,
do you think the one child policy was effective?
Yeah.
Yes.
Therefore you put it,
make a guess.
I know you don't have
right about there.
Okay.
That's the great leap forward decline.
The one child policy starts here.
Levels off.
This decline taking about 10 years was though during the won,
she shall period during the,
the,
um,
during the more or less voluntary a period that the big drop in Chinese
fertility happens here.
And then they introduced the one child policy.
Actually right about here this,
I'll just show you the actual dates or not.
So here's 1980.
The one child policy is introduced here and immediately the fertility rises and
then stabilizes.
And I'll show you later.
Eventually.
It does slow down for all kinds of reasons.
Let me go back.
So the,
the important thing to know is that it was the 19th steps.
This,
the drop is 1970 19 in this 10 years,
the 10 years before the one trial policy is when Chinese fertility really took
this,
uh,
enormous drunk.
And,
uh,
what happened was an until the 1970s,
as I've described,
there were really no family planning services and the vast rural areas and only
limited facilities and in a few of the large cities,
but starting in the 1970s as part of this policy,
contraceptives were made available,
a huge amount of propaganda.
I was made to counteract any taboos.
I mean,
peasant people have water to booze and established late marriage and the small
family as the desirable norm.
And uh,
this,
this drop we've seen drops something like this fast since then.
But this drop,
it was at the time just incredible,
uh,
to,
foreign observers that in,
in one decade to go down from six to half year for more than half your failures
is about two and a half in one decade in a place as so vast.
And so traditional is trying to,
was at that time just unbelievable.
I mean,
it turned out to be true.
The Chinese statistics were indeed,
uh,
quite good on this.
And,
uh,
it,
it shows what a family planning program in this case introduced with the full,
uh,
effort of,
of,
of the government,
uh,
can really accomplish.
And scholar said is the most extraordinary reduction in fertility and a large
population ever recorded in human history.
But in 1979,
the results of the second national census,
uh,
were released and it was clear that the population was approaching 1 billion
people.
Now to us nowadays,
you know,
we're used to hearing of China as having more than a billion people.
But back then,
the idea of a single country having a billion people was absolutely mind
boggling.
And remember,
1979 was way before the economic miracle.
So these were a billion,
very poor people,
uh,
that were going to be on earth.
And as the Chinese saw it,
very explicitly sought the population they had had very good economic gains to
the time.
Nothing like the boom that happened later.
But they really had made good progress,
but they perceive their population growth had eaten up all of their gains.
So for instance,
uh,
gay grain production increased in any rate of 2.3% between 57 and 78 the year
before the census.
But per capita consumption,
which had started extremely low,
increased only 0.2% during this time.
So it's very small,
huge production increase in production,
2.3% per year over a 10 year,
20 year period.
21 year period is very,
very good.
But when your population grows,
it nearly the same rate.
You end up with a very tiny improvement in standard of living
housing,
spaced increased by half a billion square meters.
They went on a house and home building,
you know,
poor small home,
but,
but something,
a half a billion square meters,
meters like a square yard.
Uh,
but uh,
but because,
but the per capita,
because population growth,
the per capita housing was down from 4.5 square meters to 3.6 square meters per
capita,
the s three s three meters or nine feet by nine feet,
you know.
And that was what the per capita housing down in this period of,
of,
uh,
of an improving economy.
The arable land fell from a quarter of an acre in 1949 from a half an acre in
1949 to a quarter of an acre in 83.
And it's gone down since then.
Also the government from the census realized how young the population was and a
young population means what's going to happen,
momentum that the,
there,
there are so many more young people coming into reproductive age than one's
leaving it,
that you're going to have a lot more child bearers.
And they realize this from the 1982 senses a little bit.
Another census they took the population period was 45 million women in their
forties leaving reproductive age,
60 million,
one third bigger in their thirties 80 million in their twenties and 125 million
women in their teens.
So if the teens are coming,
just starting to come into reproductive ages,
that means basically a tripling of the number of child bearing women coming into
three times as many childbearing women were coming into reproductive age as
relieving reproductive age.
Uh,
so even though they had achieved this books,
this a rather incredible fertility decline,
they realize that because of momentum,
that population would keep growing,
uh,
for,
for decades yet.
And they were really worried about it.
So at that time the TFR was something like 2.5 when they're deciding what to do
with it.
And
if they're not,
if you have at this age distribution,
this time,
2.5 children per women,
and if three times as many women are going to enter reproductive age,
uh,
what do you have to do to keep this down?
You have to go,
it's mathematically you have to have one third,
you know,
three times as many women,
you have to have one third.
The number of births they were having here,
three times,
many women to keep the number of children their son.
And because you don't reduce the number of babies,
you have to reduce fertility by one third,
so 2.5 divided by three is 0.8 so the demographics of their current fertility
loaf,
low fertility rate 2.5 the current low fertility rate,
but the tripling of of women coming into reproductive ages,
the mathematics tells you you have to say you have to get somehow get your
fertility rate down to 0.8 and they decided that was going to be very difficult.
And the institute,
the one child policy at that time,
at the lowest,
their birth rate had ever been probably forever in Chinese history was exactly
the time that they introduced the one child policy
years after implementation.
They were like an [inaudible] 86 which is six years,
seven years after implementation.
There's still a million more births than the worthy or earlier that the number
of births kept rising.
The policy was not a success in the sense in the extreme sense of the Chinese
government wanted it to be.
They wanted to keep the year in the year 2000.
They want her to keep their population under one under 1.2 billion.
When they started this they were,
they were like 800 and something billion and they were desperately hoping to
keep it under 1.2 billion and they didn't do it.
Uh,
it was 1.3 billion.
So
on paper the policy was quite draconian.
Um,
in the 82 83 regulations included,
each village would get a quota for the number of births that year in the
village.
Leaders would have to ration this out on the basis of a waiting list.
And of course only couples with no prior children could get on the list that a
mandatory IUD insertion,
uh,
for women who already had one child.
And if a woman had an unauthorized pregnancy and abortion was supposed to be
mandatory,
and you,
you heard the story about that really you should note that again,
it wasn't,
the government had nothing.
The abortion that,
that Chink told you about had nothing to do in one sense that nothing
immediately to do with the government.
She did the abortion way before anybody knew about it,
who coworkers didn't know about it at her workplace,
didn't know about government officials,
didn't know about it.
It was the suasion.
It was the effect from other people.
It was these village,
these committees that would keep visiting you and keep bugging you that cost her
say,
okay,
I'm going to avoid all this pain and just have the abortion right away.
So in a sense the government didn't have to do anything about it.
The spectrum abortion,
the statistics are very interesting in China that sometime a little after this,
uh,
unmarried sexuality started happening in traditional China that at least
officially just plain didn't happen.
But as the country modernizers one of the things you get into is,
is,
is unmarried sexuality.
And so girls were getting pregnant in an unmarried state and this was an
unthinkable sort of thing.
So what happened to those girls that were pregnant?
Non-Married their parents forced them to have an abortion.
So some statistics show that the number of abortions,
which parents required their daughters,
their unmarried pregnant daughters to have exceeded the number of abortions
forced under the one child policy because the one Jon Pelz also push
contraceptives.
So actually,
and contraception were decent.
So the number of abortions while high was not not off,
off,
off the map.
So,
uh,
the one child policy proceeded then.
There were absolutely no doubt about major human rights violations.
You heard about one story forced sterilizations forced abortions is absolutely
happened.
Uh,
and this was as you heard,
especially true if people had government jobs or worked in government own
factories and that was a big fraction of the economy.
Remember this was a socialist state and uh,
and abortion pills to be mandatory and sterilization,
even for any couple that had two more children.
Did they have
number of children dropped off
two adopted children.
So I mean a lot of people weren't supposed to have more than one child.
Yeah.
So did people didn't go through it.
You are able to manage to have another child and drop their kids off it again?
Yes,
I haven't.
I haven't seen good statistics about that.
And I don't know if the Chinese government,
let's help good statistics on that.
But the huge number of girls,
almost all girls were sent to two orphanages and
because of the poverty of the orphanages mean it was a lot of rural orphanages
that didn't have much money to begin with.
They basically couldn't take care of the babies.
Huge death rate,
huge maltreatment rate.
This is when American started adopting Chinese babies kind of en masse and many
Americans went over to pick up the baby and the stories that came back about,
you know,
children just tied into the May,
she hated soars over the body and really very,
very bad situations.
So yes,
yes,
indeed.
As far as we can tell,
but I don't have good statistics.
Yes.
A big surge in,
in voters,
given girl girl babies given up to orphanages.
Um,
okay.
So in this,
Oh boy,
I guess it's time to finish.
We'll just have to continue this next time I'm cutting into our next lecture.